So in CUDA a stream is a sequence of operations that will execute in order on the GPU.
And the particular operations we care about are memory transfers and kernel launches.
If I perform a cudaMemcpyAsync, launch kernel A,
then perform a second cudaMemcpyAsync and then launch kernel B,
then each operation completes before the next starts.
So the first Memcpy happens, then kernel A runs to completion.
Then the second Memcpy happens and then the second kernel runs.
But if I do those same operations and this time I put them each in a different stream
by adding a parameter which is the stream,
then now these operations can potentially run concurrently, therefore completing in much less time.
So this operation is in stream 1, this operation is in stream 2,
this operation is in stream 3, this operation is in stream 4.
Since we didn't specify a stream for any of these,
we would say that they are in the default stream, which happens to be stream 0.
A couple of notes. A CUDA stream object is of type cudaStream_t.
For example, here we declare a stream called s1.
You create streams using the cudaStreamCreate call,
passing in a pointer to the stream you want to create, and you destroy them by calling cudaStreamDestroy.
And remember, to get asynchronous memory transfers
you need to be using cudaMemcopyAsync, which in turn must be called on pinned host memory.